hello everyone and welcome to a special
Christmas welcome to a special Halloween
episode of the evident Catelynn podcast
should we have special music playing
right right right then maybe well for
those of you guys who are listening to
the audio only version the two of us are
in our backyard there's a nice Pleasant
cheery fire and we're gonna be telling
scary stories today talking about
Halloween traditions and I'm just having
this special edition of the podcast
because it's great weather outside and
we thought that'd be fun yeah so I think
first I was spending of like updates we
have going on this week basically I mean
y'all know October's been crazy busy but
we do have one very exciting update team
trees we are part of team team if you
guys haven't seen the YouTube videos yet
basically hundreds of youtubers are
gathering together and we're trying to
make a positive change in the world
we're trying to raise money to plant
trees all around the world
the goal is 20 million trees by 2020 and
so to do that we are trying to raise 20
million dollars I think it's at like 3
something dollars last time I checked in
two days yeah which is like pretty
insane that's pretty insane and so I
mean you guys I feel like the videos
will continue to roll out because the
launch was on Friday
we did ours we launched our video
announcing a Friday because that's when
we announced videos I think some people
it'll be like continuing to roll out
yeah and I could see even more people
who maybe you weren't a part of it
initially joining in after seeing it and
I know some of the original people who
started this movement
I know mr. beast Mark Rover and Destin
from smarter every day they were kind of
some of the original instigators and
they've kind of opened it up saying
whoever wants to make videos about this
whoever wants to raise awareness let's
keep this going
YouTube channel yeah yeah so um that's
pretty cool
I think it's Annie
thing and it's it's really cool to be
part of a bigger initiative like this
yeah it's and this is something they
kind of mentioned you know when when it
was brought up to all of us behind the
scenes before we M before the public
launch but you know it seems like
there's a lot of bad press for youtubers
these days and there's kind of a bad
public image well I think that's because
it's easier to write news articles when
things go wrong and YouTube is such a
big place and there's so many youtubers
of course there's gonna be bad things
happening it doesn't like we aren't
interesting news stories like most thing
we do is record a podcast outside by the
fire special special edition Caitlin has
like scary makeup on do you probably
can't even see it I just put on makeup
like I did in high school so it's just
all black roundish a dode like I'm extra
tired in the in the fibers DIY stained
glass resin video like you guys you guys
look really tired a cute one has some
fixed circles we were tired we're still
tired I'll just start wearing makeup
like this in every video and throughout
October you just get like more and more
dark eye makeup as it goes we don't have
any more videos in October well oh no no
but but as we keep on filming videos in
October cuz because they're not being
released a later but yeah that's true so
Caitlyn put together the plan for this
podcast what's what's yeah well I
thought it'd be fun to tell some scary
stories I have a few you start okay so I
don't know if I've told you I know I've
told you one of these but I don't think
I've told you the other two who I'm
excited so one is it's kind of like a
series of a few weird things that
happened I had this friend in high
school and like so she would often sleep
over at our house and there were several
times where she would experience weird
things I never did but she would
experience really weird stuff
at your house at my house and did she
experience them elsewhere to know what
yeah well she was she was kind of the
type to like be a little bit more like
so I have weird intuitions and stuff
like that
yeah um which I've never I have a lot of
people in my family that are like that
but I've never been that way I've never
had like cool intuitions and stuff I
always wanted them but anyways so a
couple weird things that happened one
was actually I think both of these might
have been in the same night or like the
same week um but one was she was
sleeping over and we were both in my
room and she woke up in the middle of
the night and she swore that she saw
like a shadowy figure standing by the
end of the bed like woke up looked over
saw something there which was super
weird and like it was very out of the
blue because I mean she like I said she
was kind of like intuitive about stuff
but that's not something like it was
kind of out of character yeah to just be
like um I saw a shadowy figure by the
end of your bed just standing over us
was it like did it have any features or
a hat or a mask a newsboy cap yes
features I don't know morphus figure
burn yeah tall shadowy figure then
another thing and I think this is
because she wouldn't sleep in my room
after that what so when she would sleep
over instead she started sleeping in the
there was like a kind of bonus room
upstairs outside of our rooms with a
couch and so she would sleep there and
then there was one night where she heard
like this dripping noise start and like
she couldn't go to sleep she was kept
hearing this dripping noise to where she
was like okay maybe someone left on a
sink
and she like she's pretty comfortable at
our house like she was there a lot so
she was like okay I'm just gonna like
check the kitchen check you know the
guest bathrooms and this and that she
walked all over the place in the house
could not find the source of the noise
like it was seemingly the same volume in
most places in the house like there
wasn't a clue to where it was and she
couldn't could never figure it out and
then another time where she was sleeping
on that couch she woke up by what she
described as a sickening gurgling noise
whoa I know right
maybe the figure was standing over by
her by that maybe maybe wanted her to do
with me yeah man that's crazy
I in this house in our current house in
our current house I was trying to sleep
in the living room one day because I was
sick and I didn't want to like keep you
up by rolling around and I heard like
this humming fan and I just couldn't
find it I walked all the way all around
the house and I like checked the fridge
I like is the fridge making this weird
noise like I how could I not notice that
there's this loud humming noise in our
house well it was at night and all the
other sounds were gone I was like what's
not what's this hum what's this hum it
was driving me crazy and I I was like I
forget which period of sickness it was
but I was like sick for like a few days
in a row and the second day I was like I
just gotta find this and it was a
mosquito catcher right outside the
mysterious humming noise you know one
thing that happened to me that like it
was one of the scariest things that
happen but it it wasn't like a like
spooky ghost things or anything it was
just times I've been the most scared I
was in my first apartment and I mean it
was in aid ok area of town it wasn't
like the best area of town it wasn't
great it wasn't great it was medium it
wasn't like terrifying but it wasn't
great and in this apartment complex like
I'd seen a car get its tires stolen
there was once where I came home and
everything was roped off because someone
had been shot like some scary stuff had
happened and there's one night where and
I I lived alone there's one night where
so the apartment had like an alarm
system and the alarm started going off
in the middle of the night it never
happened before him I freaked out like
turn on all the lights Juby went running
and hiding under the bed because it was
super loud and I like go to the kitchen
I grabbed a kitchen knife so I got
nothing you know that's all I got and
I'm like looking around and no doors are
open which is good but of course someone
could have come in and shut the door
yeah like turn off the alarm so I can
hear things and think straight and I
never figured out what it was like in
that moment later on I think what it was
is like there's just a little bit of
give on my like balcony door to where it
could throw off the sensors and even
with the doors being locked and closed
it would set it off cuz it happened once
more later on another night and then I
was like I'm just not using this alarm
anymore cuz it's terrifying to wake up
in the middle of the night with your
like alarm going off that only goes off
when an entry sensor opens man in like a
kind of sketchy area so that's why you
sleep with your butcher knife at night
by the bedside table yeah man I haven't
had that many scary experiences that I
can remember I mean when I was younger I
didn't I'm not sure if there's a call
though like a reoccurring nightmare or
what but I always saw like red lights
like power lights or like electronic
lights on like VCRs or TVs or whatever I
sometimes some nights I'd wake up and
I'd see those lights around the house
not think that they're like skeleton
eyes are like creepy eyes when I was
younger yeah I was like I guess light
year that I had yeah we rob like see
things everyone sees Oh like shapes and
figures wake up so vividly when I
remember one time I had to get up and I
had like hit it and like remove the
object so it wasn't making that shape
anymore this I could stop picturing it
as that thing I was like nope sometimes
I mean like when you're young though
your imagination just runs so wild like
there was once I remember it's so
distinctly and vividly and this is the
main time I remember like seeing
something that wasn't there but I was
sleeping in my parents room and they had
like we had like a closed-in patio and
there was a door from their room to the
patio that had like these really big
kind of sheer curtains yeah in front of
it and I saw a like cartoony monster man
it was like a cartoon like a 2d
illustration and he was sitting at a
table with other monsters in our patio
he came to the curtains he bit the
curtains and then he went back it wasn't
really scary cartoon monster I think
they were playing poker at their table
and he lost the bet or something not
scary I wasn't really scared I was just
like that's weird
have you ever had night terrors I've had
where like you feel like you can't
breathe yeah what is that oh I don't
know of this the name for it is sleep
paralysis paralysis that said yeah I
don't know if what I had is like extreme
enough to call sleep paralysis okay so I
don't know you guys probably know what
that is but no fires getting poppy it's
like where you wake up in the middle of
the night you are your brain is
conscious but you can't move your body
in any way you can't you can't do
anything you can't make a noise you feel
like a pressure is on your chest yeah
I've
I've never I don't think I've ever
experienced it where I like thought I
was awake I've experienced things where
like in the dream I needed to move in
order I needed to yell and I couldn't I
started kind of like having that same
kind of panic attack where I remember
waking you up from one really like you
were you were sleeping but like your
breathing was elevated and like in my
sleep I picked up your breathing was
wrong and I woke up and then I woke you
up and then he said like oh my gosh
things cuz I was like stuck it's
freaking out yeah yeah I don't I don't
think that's definitely had sleep
paralysis oh you woke up yeah you you
help me it's like oh yeah I woke up I
didn't know that it was like I I didn't
know if it was more of what I
experienced or if you were like oh I was
conscious I was conscious I was in bad I
couldn't move I couldn't do anything I
couldn't say anything so I was like
trying to like like really like move or
say something or do anything yeah and
then like I could I think I could
slightly control my breathing so I tried
to breathe loudly and irregularly and
slap you right is like like laying bagel
love you you help me or something I
think I think that was stress-related
probably it seems like the kind of thing
that would be brought on by stress I
think at that period in our lives we
were just really stressed you know it
has been pretty stressful but we have
just given up things we haven't been
streaming as much we haven't been doing
as many things about like I feel like
we've been managing it fairly well
better than we used to better than we
used to
October is almost done and we still have
like the first week of November also
it's kind of crazy but we only have one
and a half more projects until we're out
of this crazy period
[Laughter]
so some other spooky stories um cuz like
also for me I would like seek out spooky
stuff yeah you know cuz you're spooky
child child and um once my parents like
my family were going to Savannah because
I almost I almost went to a Savannah
College of Art and Design so we're like
Oh we'll make like a little trip out of
it because we're visiting and stuff and
there's this really haunted hotel there
called the Marshall House mhm and it
didn't used to be a hotel it was like a
house and then during the Civil War it
was used for like it was like a soldier
Hospital and then during like in the
19th century I I had to look up some of
the like dates and facts because I
couldn't remember them exactly in the
19th century it was used as like a
hospital again for like yellow fever
patients and so a lot of people died in
that house and later on it was turned
into a hotel but it's like from like the
19th century who made that decision well
I mean you know well I don't know if
it's the same in all right I don't know
in some places I feel like it's you kind
of lean into it and people like yeah New
Orleans and stuff yeah so it worked for
you yeah and so my dad like got us a
reservation to stay there like the two
days we were there I'm so excited
um and a couple strange things happen
and I looked up like what the common
strange occurrences are and there's like
a whole before after after after like
just now oh wow cuz I was like I wonder
if any of the things we experienced like
Oh God
yeah um the things that we experienced
and of course like as with any scary
stuff I could probably be exploring
anyway but still because we were in like
a creepy place so one was are like me
and my brother were staying in one room
and then my parents were in another room
and so in our room we had latched the
balcony door there was like it wasn't
really a balcony you could step up up on
it was like one of those old-timey ones
where you just kind of open the window
and there's like a little gate and you
can take like one step so they had one
of those and we had like opened it up to
check it out and we locked it behind us
when we when we left and we just like
went downstairs for a little bit because
there was like a little courtyard area
that my parents were at and we came back
up and it was open which was super weird
cuz like no one had been in the room and
we had latched it and it was like not a
kind of latch it was like the kind of
our little hook goes down into so it was
closed but I latched no we closed and
latched it yeah you close and latch it
but it was it was closed and open open
and and unlatched yeah when we got back
and we were like what cuz we not been
down that long then another thing is
just like our radio turning on and off
on its own it had like a old-school
radio yeah and that's one of the things
that apparently happens like is like
electronics turning on and off on their
own there's like a whole list of a big
list of things that people experience
but that was one of them another one
kind of related to the latch maybe is
like people hearing like doorknobs
jiggle like someone's trying to get in
but then no one's there that happen to
you but it's kind of crazy I wonder like
I wonder if you could that'd be a good
oh that'd be a really good Halloween
project like make a darn hundred jiggly
sorry I was thinking like would be
easier might be that like radio an old
like a radio that turns on and off yeah
boombox
music yes or like a Bluetooth speaker
that just randomly start playing creepy
music it's like what if it's like paired
to you like so it's like like I I make a
Bluetooth speaker or I buy a Bluetooth
speaker for you but then I hack it so
that like I can take over the Bluetooth
connection and play local stuff instead
so you're just like at your desk and
then the Bluetooth speaker it turns on
starts playing spooky things
that would be pretty spooky I'd be a
good project that I have no good habit
of like where our expertise lies can I
use resin to make that happen
I don't know I mean as resin is okay I
do have one more scary story that is not
my own but it is my family's mm-hmm and
I might have heard this one you might
have heard this on okay well you guys
cuz it's a cool story so my dad's family
my grandmother on that side is very like
intuitive to things yeah I mean like
very much so and the house they lived in
was haunted and she would experience
stuff all the time you know like things
getting knocked off of dressers and this
and that and you know little things here
and there and they were having a dinner
party and you know they're all like
having dinner and this and that and they
are in the dining room and in the dining
room there are these little mirrored
tiles on the walls and she was telling
people some of the stories about spooky
stuff that had happened and people were
kind of like laughing it off slightly
like yeah sure you know whatever being
doubters and then the mirrored tiles
started popping off the walls one by one
and shattering onto the floors how many
fell off I don't know okay I didn't ask
the specific number like a lot of
multiple multiple multiple and later on
that house burned down haunted haunted
did they find the cause of the fire the
ghosts official record by that the by
the department of fire and ghosts arson
yep it's official yeah so you don't have
as many scary stories I don't have as
many scary stories I don't have a shot
them out more or maybe I'm just very
forgetful and we'll have to ask my
parents because I'm also very forgetful
do you have oh so we were talking about
Halloween traditions the other day but I
thought it'd be fun to like bring some
of those up especially because one of
one of my traditions you were a part of
long before we were dating because I
used to always have Halloween parties at
my house Salem Caitlyn's favorite time
of the year by far is Halloween Jesus
likes Halloween a lot I mean you like
Christmas too you like traditions in
general yeah I like Christmas but like
and I get excited about Christmas but
Halloween it's it's it fits your
personality especially from like that
point in your life yes yes I used to I
mean I I was the type okay that
trick-or-treated like until I was much
older than most most kids because I
wanted like hold on to the tradition but
then in high school I was old enough to
start having parties at my house these
are all sanctioned parties by my parents
my mom helped me plan them and decorate
my parents were there nothing no funny
business going but so once I was in high
school I started having having parties
and we would go like oh and you came to
one of those parties came to the last
one actually oh my god my parents moved
that year so glad I got to go to one I'm
sure she did go all out she like had
crazy decorations they had like a lot of
trees in their back yard and she had
like like so my mom and I would like get
on ladders and wrap you know the big
sheets of spiderweb we would wrap
clusters of trees with spider web to
create like a spider web
room and then it was like we would light
it all creepy sometimes if there was
enough space like within the room we put
like a fire in there and some chairs
it's like if you were in there you're in
this creepy little seance room but it
wasn't just that like from the beginning
as you approached there is like spooky
stuff inside there is spooky stuff
there's spooky stuff like along the
entire path to the backyard like yeah
the whole house was decked out in spooky
yeah one thing we did that I think I had
forgotten about it until we were talking
about it the other day
um and it's probably the reason why I
did our wedding backdrop the way that we
did cuz our wedding backdrop was like
strips of fabric that I dyed and like we
made this like stand together and tied
them and it was like a happy blue and
pink and fun color yeah but what I did
for Halloween was I took the same like
cheap fabric and ripped it into strips
and we would like rub it around in the
dirt so I get really dirty and we would
tie it to the trees like hundreds of
strips of fabric all throughout like the
tons of trees in the backyard and it was
so creepy I mean it kind of looks like
when a house gets toilet paper it
honestly better mordent better more
dense and like dirtier yeah like it's
not gonna fall apart if it rains no no
what I kind of like would like to see
now that same thing but mix like
Nightmare Before Christmas style with
string lights just like string lights
and creepy spooky muslin fabric yeah
it's so good like it's just something
all the way like moves and the wind yeah
it's so creepy but you can get like
yards and yards of it for super cheap so
it makes a really big impact you can
technically reuse it you know you just
wash it okay so you know we're gonna do
when we care about the appearance of our
backyard during a holiday season what we
can do is for Halloween will do the
spooky fabric and then as soon as it's
not Halloween anymore and it's
approaching Christmas we'll go back and
we'll dip dye every other one green and
every other one red and then all of a
sudden it's Christmas themed in some
ways like no more Christmassy Christmas
yeah I guess that would be another
tradition as we always we always try to
watch Nightmare Before Christmas a
couple of years yeah yeah you get two
chances to watch a Nightmare Before
Christmas
I know but really one makes a little bit
more sense yeah it's more of a Halloween
movie there's more of a Halloween but
maybe that's just because I feel like
there's like other more Christmassy
Christmas movies yeah I want to put one
more log in the fire oh yeah
okay yes yes do you have any favorite
scary movies scary movies that are
actually scary or scary movies that are
not as scary um hocus-pocus is a pretty
that's a good Halloween awesome
Halloween movie that is a really good
one that's like a classic that you can
watch that gets you in the Halloween
spirit that's not like a scary what's
your cat's name Oh Zachary Zachary
Zachary refactored it's actually Sakura
and I did not figure that out till I was
an adult I thought it was Zachary yeah
cuz it's Thackery Binx
huh so I thought it was Zachary but she
was just lisping but no we used to have
a cat named Binks it's from Zachary
beans what's his first name
Zachary first name was Banks thanks
Sakura is his middle name
just like it's so interesting cuz I mean
maybe that was a name back then when
like when he was supposed to be from
yeah maybe I think in terms of its
actual scariness I just can't do gory
stuff it just disturbs me so a lot of
scary movies depend on that you know I
mean that's true I will say I prefer I
don't mind gory stuff but I prefer the
ones that rely a little bit more on your
imagination yeah oh you know it's the
opposite of that paranormal activity
no no paranormal activity was great or
something like that was like I think was
like mother or something like that
mama anyways that's like it was a pretty
good creepy movie until they showed the
face of the monster and then I just
couldn't take it seriously just like a
little bit derpy it was like a little
bit a little bit not scary and they have
been really been pretty good cuz I think
that point
I think the reason it was is because it
left it up to your imagination yeah
you know I just kind of felt bad for the
scary thing I was like oh I feel bad it
was kind of a sad dirty vase and I was
like oh poor thing it's like I got I got
it received my sympathy instead of my
fear at that point you know paranormal
activity was a pretty good balance for
me well I like that one the reason I
said it was opposite of like the Gorobei
stuff yeah there's like no gore no gore
Oh like if you got in the right mood and
if you got like in like like like like
you're like this imagine that you're
watching the surveillance footage and
you're just part of the experience it
was it was good yeah well I mean I feel
like with any movie you have to like
engulf yourself in it you know and so I
think you couldn't I mean I enjoyed it I
know there's some people that thought
like not enough stuff yeah but I don't
think it's cause like they weren't I
felt like I was able to put myself in it
so much because like it's like you're
watching surveillance footage and you're
watching a TV you know yeah it kind of
fit with that it felt it felt it felt
like that I was able to immerse myself
more easily because it's kind of like
bad it's kind of like you have YouTube
feels more real than movies or TV shows
it's like that felt almost more real to
me lower quality cameras and stuff and
like I don't know the budget was so low
well and also they didn't use any
well-known actors yeah which I think
helps a lot because like it would
totally break it if it was like oh
there's I don't know just a normal
family with some ghosts yeah yeah that
was one of my favorites I mean but I
mean like the opposite of that is like
some of those gross scary movies we
watched with our I just couldn't I just
nope I there's no doubt there it's like
hung out on the patio with our friends
that went out I stuck it out and I don't
think I'm better for it I probably
they're disturbing disturbing it's just
like once those things get into your
head they can't leave you can't unsee
something flowers let's move on move on
move on no one that I really liked was
the ring the ring was good I really
liked the ring like the ring didn't rely
on like over scary as much it was
there's good balance I felt like it was
a good balance it it's still like left a
lot of mystery and all kind of like the
final scene yeah when everything went
down you know but I I liked the like
mystery involved in it too I thought it
was cool and there's like a cool story
and again something about like cuz a big
part of the creepy stuff was like the
tape yeah you know which you're watching
like surveillance footage I don't know
why that's so creepy
but it's cuz it like feels more real
yeah you know so you're watching this
like tape and all the creepy stuff on
the tape that kind of reminds me of like
so so one thing we considered for this
was reading no sleep stories I know this
I think Jen and Julianne do on the Jenna
Jillian podcast and with no sleep
stories because I read a bunch of them
it's like what are your favorite things
well my favorite things are ones that so
there's different these urban style
stories some are very like well-written
where it's like they describe the
setting they set up the story they set
up the characters it's all very like
it's like reading a book the best is as
if the person writing it is like posting
to get it right yeah the best is if like
it feels like just a normal person
they're not giving you these like
brilliantly written setups and there's a
lot of ones like that where it's like
they're updates
so there's live updates there's one I
follow that like updated over the course
of a year
was it this poor one come back to town
that was a good series a good month and
then there'd be another wine and it was
like oh my god what's happen
now what's happening in the town yeah
you know and it builds upon itself and
it's written like like okay this date
this time here's what's going on
something's weird and it like builds up
almost like a diary and then some other
ones that I really like that are
different but again kind of have that
like realism feel are the ones that are
like you know I I used to be an EMT and
like I've seen some really crazy stuff I
thought I'd share some of my stories
nice things like that yeah
you know it'd be great a podcast that
was a serialized like audio diary of
someone going through like like if they
had of like the the infected town it had
have been like an audio diary and like
they could have had some practical
effects like they were there like
they're walking through the thing or
they like heard some things but like it
was all like told as if it was like
someone with this zoom recorder right
here telling the story like live that'd
be so good I wonder something like that
exists probably probably I wonder if
it's good maybe yeah there's there's
something about like stuff that is shot
as if it's real that I think I think
I'll you said I think it does suck you
in extra or so it's written as if it's
real yeah you can easily pretend like
it's real yeah it's like the like you
probably could put yourself and like
imagine anything is real but like if you
almost don't realize that that's what
you're doing as you're watching it yeah
you know it has a bigger effect on some
people I guess yeah do you have any like
things from when you were younger that
were super creepy I think the only thing
is imagining shapes imagining things in
the night and the sleep paralysis that I
have had that would freak me out yeah I
feel like when you're a kid it's like
extra freaky yeah plus you don't have
someone next to you that you can just
like breathe loudly towards ya you know
I this isn't really a creepy experience
but like it is it was kind of freaky
when we were living abroad my brother
had a really really high fever hmm like
a hundred and two hundred and three
years something so he was kind of like
hallucinating at night and we were all
kind of checking on him but um I had a
room next to him and I heard him like
making noises so I went on in to check
on him and I was like 13 he was 14 or so
and he was just taking everything off
the walls
I'd be so freaked out he was just taking
everything off the walls like all the
painting this everything and he was like
taking putting all on the floor and I
like Eric was going on and he's like
it's too heavy for the walls the walls
are gonna collapse it's all gonna
collapse and he was like obsessed with
like he just thought that the walls were
just too heavy and it was all gonna fall
in and yeah that's creepy that's like
something that would happen in a scary
movie yeah but I I knew it was a fever
but like like what if I had what if I
didn't know that he was having a fever
dream yeah what if you were
significantly younger like or what if
like I was away at my friend's place or
something and he suddenly caught a fever
and it went crazy and then came back and
for some reason my parents didn't tell
me that my brother's there with a fever
and like I'm just like in my room and I
hear that I walk in and that's what he's
doing
that'd be creepy have you ever had fever
dreams are like weird fever
hallucinations I never have I never have
right now make your brain malfunction
and I have had lucid dreams quite a bit
and I love it Oh lucid dreams are the
best you haven't had any have you my
dreams
really what are you doing yet in them I
just gonna I mean I don't really fight
it too much I just kind of like follow
along with the dream yeah like where it
takes me like those of you who haven't
maybe heard of lucid dreaming is you're
dreaming but then you're semi-conscious
in
the dream and I have control over my
dream do you have any control over your
dream I I don't know I've never tried to
control it it's you should do it I feel
like it wake myself up no no no no if
you get good at it it's like you kind of
like part way wake up and then you're
still dreaming and then if you can like
stay in that dream state then like it's
like your imagination is insane it's I
feel like I'm talking like about drugs
or something like that but like this is
like but like completely natural you
just go to sleep and like as you're
waking up if you can enter this state
it's really pretty awesome and for some
reason all of mine are like action
movies or like sci-fi movies or like
related to a book I read or a movie I've
seen or something like that and I guess
I mean my brain just like takes all of
that world that's built up in these
books or movies or whatever and all of a
sudden I'm in there and I can like you
know have special powers or something I
can fly I can breathe it underwater
standard dream things that some people
do but like I remember this one lucid
dream that I had that was from I forget
which episode of Star Wars but it was
epic it was it was really cool it was um
I think the second one where Anakin was
like the teenager and the he had the
crush on the princess yeah and I think
that the princess almost got
assassinated through the window
I think r2d2 saved her or something like
that cuz he detected like the thing and
I watched this movie like once when it
first came out but anyways Anakin jumps
out of the window rashly and starts
running around on the the flying cars
that are in the city you know so it's
like the assassin was far away and shot
through the window like this slug that
like was gonna like and finally thoughts
like why didn't he just shoot the
princess but like I think what it did it
was like it shot like a canister that
deployed like this poisonous snake
just shoot a grenade in there yeah you
got like rocket launchers yeah well if
you're able to get in there just just do
the thing bottles come on come on now so
I jumped like I was I was Anakin and I
was like running through the Skyway I
was like jumping off of flying cars
chasing this person I took over a flying
car and I was like flying it around and
like dodging and diving and like
maneuvering this flying car chasing this
this villain and it was pretty epic and
you were controlling it yeah I could
kind of like control it some I could
like control the plot if I wanted to
like be in the car more I could be in
the car more if I wanted to like jump
and fly around some more I could do that
I can kind of like somewhat rewind and
move there like movie forwards and
backwards I couldn't like change who I
was or the world I was in or whatever
but you can tweak little things you can
like change scene not not change scenes
to kids like it is actually pretty
continual and linear but you can kind of
like I could kind of fast-forward and
rewind it and then I could like change
the plot it was like kind of like choose
your own adventure mm-hmm if you know I
mean yeah but you just have a lot of
choices in a way but it has to be kind
of within the world thats populated and
flushed out in your mind because you
know your brain can do so much your
brain can only do so much but like since
all of the world was flushed out I knew
what the general powers were I knew like
the city and the the scene it was all
set for me and it sobs of a nightmare in
a way but like it's a it's an awesome
dream I I've had some recurring dreams
that were creepy that spanned like years
well were they so a lot of the specifics
I don't remember the main oh yeah I
think you told me this which one the the
juubi oh no that's a different one scary
oh no and I still have these I haven't
had it in a while but it was just like
there's this house mm-hmm
and sometimes I recognize that it's the
house because I'm seeing the same things
in the house but sometimes I'm in a
different part of the house that I
haven't been in before like the Attic
for example but I just know it's the
same house and so like that's the Lucid
part of it for me is that like awareness
that I'm in the place I've dreamed about
before and I know I'm in a dream but I'm
still in this house and so I'll like
explore it and stuff but there's a house
from your real world experiences no it's
like a made-up house and I couldn't I
have bits and pieces of pictures of what
it looks like like I know that there's
rafters in the ceiling like it's kind of
an older house but I couldn't tell you
specifics but I've I've had like dozens
of dreams where I'm in this house it
hasn't happened in a long time probably
not since like College Wow but it was
from like childhood to college and it
could still be going on now I'll be
honest I used to every time I would have
a dream when I woke up as soon as I woke
up I would write it down yeah cuz that's
when it's freshest I almost want to read
through some of those I haven't been
down i have scary dreams written down a
lot of them are in that house yeah what
if that was next
Halloween's reading Kaitlyn's scary
dream oh my gosh
yeah these days because I don't write
them down I feel like I also don't
remember them as well yeah sometimes we
talk about what we dreamed about when we
wake up but sometimes we don't yes most
times you forgotten most times a because
usually I wake up a little bit before
you yeah so if I haven't told you like
immediately it's already left yeah you
know you have to do it like right when
you wake right when you wake up so I
could still be having dreams about that
house and just not do it
what if in real life I go to that house
and I recognize it
that'd be so freakin crazy just walk in
and it's like I've been here and then
run away yes it's like my entire life
has been leading me to this house and
then run by it so we can destroy it then
maybe just buy the curse if you buy it
then it you take it with you yeah yeah
yeah
your other scary dream is about like
this one's more realistically sad it's
not always sad but um so one dream that
I didn't really start having until I got
joob but like I often I still have
dreams were like because she's so she's
an inside cat I know there's mixed
feelings about that but when I got her
in the location I was in that was the
best for her and then she got used to it
and it's not always good to like change
change and we just thought that that was
the best for her so she's an inside cat
um it's looked over to see if she's
there
and I will often have dreams about like
I'm I'm in an unfamiliar house and joobs
there too and either she keeps getting
out and I can't find like I've swept the
house I've looked for every possible
exit and I can't find it or other cats
are getting in but cats or other animals
but usually other cats and we've lost
druvan this bundle yeah you'd think
that'd be awesome for me but no because
like I worry about jube I worry about
her getting like like swept away with
the other cats I worry about like the
other cats like biting her or scratching
her or if there's a hole where cats can
get in guys can get out get out too and
so I'm like searching for jube and
there's all these other cats in the
house and I can't find her and I'm in
like a panic and like every time I find
her she just ends up getting out again
or more cats are getting in and I just
like have this over one of cats trying
to get into the house and I can't keep
her safe
I can't keep like an eye on her because
it's like trying to plug a faucet you
know okay like that fan of stays over
Mickey this keeps on getting more and
more and more water
there's cops yeah exactly do you think
it'd be a dream all right like yeah like
a positive dream but it's very stressful
because I'm trying to take care of one
particular cat yes I also this was back
when I had hamsters I would often dream
that like like the hamster was my
responsibility and for some reason like
I forgot the hamster existed for like
three months and I was like I haven't
fed the hamster I haven't cleaned the
hamsters cage is the hamster still a lot
it's kind of like the dreams that
everyone has about school about that
class that they thought that they had
yeah very hamster specific version of
that oh my gosh still yes I just like
have dreams about like not being able to
take care of my animal responsibilities
well the fire is dying down a little bit
is there anything else on the list I
think we can close it out okay time for
thing of the week
I feel like we should replace all of
those with scary versions okay just this
just this one time
yeah what's my thing of the week I wrote
it down it's it's my new video okay so
my thing of the week is a video from
Michael Reeves and he set up a Twitter
algorithm so that when people tweet at
him an item on Amazon this within a
certain price range this vault will
automatically by the highly most highly
ranked tweet for a time people could
vote yeah yeah so basically the internet
decided how he was gonna decorate his
room
and it would run for 24 hours he had
hundreds hundreds and hundreds of items
delivered that's a lot of packages yeah
and the internet decided I'm surprised
with the like sheer amount of BTS stuff
like did people get together on that is
a pretty big thing and I'd say maybe
don't watch it with your kids
no don't definitely don't watch it with
kids my michael reaves kid appropriate
he uses language that is not appropriate
to use around maybe posters in the video
that are not appropriate that's right
but it's also hilarious video and just
the concept so letting your fans troll
you like well especially his fans his
jokes are really quite truly I feel like
you guys would be pretty kind to us if
we did something like that people would
be pretty kind you know what Michael
should set up that bot he should
collaborate with a whole bunch of other
youtubers to do that experiment for
other youtubers do it for mr. B's but
the budget is like yes that would be
amazing
that'd be awesome yeah that would do
really well that would be a great collab
oh my gosh
that'd be that'd be great he could like
rent a place and have it like decorated
the whole house could be decorated by
the internet and then he donates it the
house you know what it's not outside the
realm of possibilities and then all the
money goes to trees yes okay so well
sure there's kind of really
it's a home decor item because really oh
yeah is it the cups that we got so many
questions and so in our guest room
makeover one of the things that we
didn't really think that we'd get that
many questions about was we had bought
these little pencil holders off Amazon
and they're like they have like a
Marbley look and they're gold rimmed and
there was like a pink marble e1 and a
gray marble you we're awesome looking
they're they're super cute and we had a
lot of questions about them so I thought
I would make my thing wait because we
really like them they're like they have
a good weight to them they're happy they
don't feel like they're gonna tip
they're a good size you can store all
sorts of things in these cups we have a
turkey baster you have a turkey baster
anyway
yeah so we got we got two of them but
all I'll put a link to them could in the
in the show notes cuz they're super cute
they're not very expensive and you guys
really like them so and I we really like
them too don't honestly the only reason
we didn't have a link to them is because
they're on Amazon it was a Lowe's video
and it's kind of like we don't wanna
push our luck yeah we don't want to like
you know step on any toes well if you
guys liked this episode let us know if
you want us to do like more special
location ones and we can see if we can
do that in the future make sure to rate
this podcast 5 pumpkins out of five
pumpkins pumpkins yes you know what what
do you even say like five ghosts out of
five ghosts or five ghosts out of five
ghosts we will accept no less ghosts yes
but I hope you guys enjoyed it and we'll
look forward to seeing you next time
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]